you can only believe
in an ends that can justify any means if
you believe in a Utopia and you can only
believe in the Utopia if you really buy
into the Promethean spirit so is that
what explains Nazism so Nazism is is
part of that too the Promethean spirit
that we can make ourselves into Superman
ubermensch right and
Nazism is fueled very much
by
appropriating and twisting
sort of Gnostic themes
that are very prevalent gnosticism can
tends to come to the fore when people
are experiencing it uh you know
increased meaning crisis and don't
forget the Weimar Republic is like a a
meeting crisis gone crazy on all levels
everybody's suffering domicide
everybody's home and way of life and
identity and culture and relationship to
religion and science all of that right
and so Nazism comes along and offers a
kind of gnosticism again Twisted
perverted I'm not saying all not I'm not
not saying that all gnostics are Nazis
but there is this Gnostic mythology
Mythos and it comes to the fore I I
remember and this stuck with me in
undergrad I was taking political science
um
and the professor extended lecture on
this and it still Rings true for me he
says if you understand Nazism as just a
political movement you have
misunderstood it it is much more a
religious phenomena
in many ways is it religious in that the
loss of religion so is it a meaning
crisis or
is it out of a meaning crisis every
discovery of religion in a in a
Promethean type uh I think it's the
latter I think there's a there's this
vacuum created in that context is Hitler
the the central religious figure yes and
also the did uh Nazi Germany create
Hitler or did Hitler create Nazi Germany
so in this distributed cognition where
everyone's having a dialogue what's the
role of the charismatic leader is it an
emergent phenomena or do you need one of
those to uh to kind of guide the
populace I hope it's not a necessary
requirement I hope that the next Buddha
can be the Sangha rather than a specific
individual
um but I think in that situation
Hitler's Charisma allowed him to take on
a mythological in the proper sense
archetypal
he became deeply symbolic and he and he
instituted all kinds of rituals all
kinds of rituals and all kinds of Mythos
there's all this Mythos about the master
race and there's all these rituals the
swastika is of course a self a religious
symbol right there's all of this going
on because
he
was tapping into the fact that when you
put people into deeper and deeper
meaning scarcity they will fall back on
more and more mythological ways of
thinking in order to try and come up
with a generative source to give them
new meaning making I should say meeting
participating
Behavior